IT'S TIME TO PLAY I'M NOT WITH
THE BAND-HEAVY: METAL EDITION.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: LIVE FAST, DIE YOUNG,
LEAVE A GOOD LOOKING CORPSE
USED TO BE ROCK-N-ROLL'S MOTTO.
NOW IT'S LIVE FAST AND LEAVE A
EMBARRASSING BAND PHOTO
FOREVER ON THE INTERNET.
WE FOUND THESE PHOTOS ON
DEATHSCREAM.NET'S 50 WORST
HEAVY METAL BANDS OF ALL TIMES.
I WILL ALREADY TELL YOU THESE
ARE AMAZING.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A BAND AND
FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO
SING ME A LYRIC FROM THAT BAND.
FIRST ONE: SAD IRON. SAD IRON.
-- MARGARET.
>> WE GOT THE SAME HARASS THE
CAST OF DESIGNING WOMEN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YES, JACK.
>> WE ARE GONNA TAKE IT -- CUASE
WE'RE LAME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
[SINGS] POINTS!
KYLE.
>> WE ARE SAD IRON AND THE SAD
IRONY IS --
THAT WE'RE REASONABLY WELL
ADJUSTED.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, TITAN FORCE.
TITAN FORCE.
[LAUGHING]
>> HEY GUYS MAKE SURE AND CHEAT
YOUR DICKS OUT TO CAMERA.
KYLE.
>> WE'RE GONNA ROCK AND WE
DON'T CARE.
WE'LL SEE YOU ALL MONTH AT THE
COUNTY FAIR.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
SINGING 'BOUT CORN AND WHEAT.
MARGARET. MARGARET.
YES.
>> WE'RE HEAVY METAL THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ABOUT. WE DON'T WATER THE
LAWN BECAUSE WE'RE IN A DROUGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: YES, VER SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS. POINTS.
THE TITAN FORCE OF BEING
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
JACK.
>> WHO OUT THERE LIKES 14
MINUTE, PROG ROCK UNLISTENABLE
KEYBOARD SOLOS, I CAN'T HEAR
YOU.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: OVER HERE IS A FARMER
WITH A SHOTGUN THAT'S LIKE YOU
BETTER GET THE [BEEP] OFF MY
PROPERTY.
NEXT ONE LUCIFER'S FRIEND.
LUCIFER'S FRIEND.
[LAUGHING]
JESUS CHRIST. THAT IS, THAT IS
LIKE A LIVING BANKSY TRIBUTE. --
[BEEP] CRAZY. KYLE.
>> I LOVE LUCY AND HE LOVES ME.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
YES, JACK.
>> PEOPLE, LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
MY BEST FRIEND.
HE'S THE SPAWN OF SATAN WHO WILL
[BEEP] ME UNTIL I DIE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
THE ORIGINAL COURTSHIP OF
EDDIE'S FATHER THEME "MISS THEE
[BLEEP] UNTIL I DIE.
MARGARET.
>> I'M A METAL DESTROYER
CAUSE I'M HERE WITH VERN TROYER.
>> CHRIS: NICE.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
HOW ABOUT REPULSA.
REPULSA. YES, JACK.
>> GREAT LORD SATAN IS THE
MASTER OF SIN.
I'LL TAKE ANOTHER ORDER OF
THE POTA-TO SKINS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS. KYLE.
>> REPULSA, I JUST MET A GIRL
NAMED REPULSA.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: I'M GIVING YOU POINTS
FOR THE COMMITMENT.
LAST ONE.
IT'S REPUSLA, IT'S ON BRAND. --
THIS IS EXORCIST.
EXORCIST.
NO, GUYS THE OPPOSITE OF THE
KLAN. MARGARET.
>> NO, IT'S KLAN HALEN.
CHRIS: YES, YES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
CHRIS: PANAMA FOR WHITES ONLY.
JACK.
>> WE'LL PUT OUR NAMES UP IN
LIGHTS AND OUR FACES IN THE SKY.
EXCEPT FOR DARYL. HE'S KIND OF
SHY.